it's really confusing to have the cat
also be named spider-man so i'll call
him tobeans maguire for clarity
after two long years of waiting since
insomniac's initial groundbreaking
superhero caper
spider-man miles morales has released
and is exactly what we were all hoping
for
a shorter but still pretty good solid
game where he plays a younger and more
inexperienced version of the series
usual hero
and save the city during christmas by
punching people with lightning
so arkham origins it looks smoother
plays more fluidly
feels more fine-tuned and from a
technical perspective is an
absolute marvel spider-man from a
gameplay standpoint miles is an upgrade
in just about
every way from improved animations and
combat to small things like cutting out
some of the less interesting sections of
the original game
like the circuit puzzles and the human
stealth no i don't have to play as that
lame
punk ass human miles i'm big strong
super miles with the fresh ass fade and
the tims
somebody please teach peter how to dress
he looks like a school teacher oh wait
yeah so let's talk about what's been
improved since there's not a lot of new
things here from the main game
if you want my thoughts on all the basic
stuff be sure to check out my review of
the original insomniacs disney's
marvel's spider-man peter parker ps4
[Applause]
well we got some vast improvements on
stealth which makes sense because miles
can turn
invisible it's a really huge step up
that you can
web people up from the walls and
ceilings again now we're back to the
level of stealth we had in 2010
the bone collector returns with the
ability to grow my nest even larger to
feed the charlie horde
i can ensnare corpses at 360 degrees
around any environment
for all the world is my nest that's not
going to be funny at all for people who
are watching my videos for the first
time
and the people who do get the joke will
get a light chuckle out of it at best
so yeah the new invisibility mechanic is
a lot of fun and gives you way more
options for stealth
but that's the trade-off with having far
less gadgets than peter
peter's stealth was about impact webbing
everyone to a wall as fast as you could
in like four seconds well this one
forces you to take your time and plan
your moves a little better
it's not as chaotic and it's a little
more engaging to have to work with less
[Music]
some spiderman
the addition of miles electric powers is
pretty cool if a little over the top
in the comics it never seemed like he
was able to just shoot lightning out of
his hands or
or absorb batteries in this game he's
just going full on static mode
cole mcgrath once again remains the only
white guy with electric powers
these new powers give miles some
interesting new gameplay mechanics
like using the venom punch to take down
big groups of enemies or heavily
shielded ones
or powering batteries and tethering
machinery together in puzzles
some of this stuff was really fun and a
nice change of pace from the usual
spider-man game combat and puzzles
i prefer this a lot to the previous
game's hacking minigames
it's a shame peter won't be able to do
this stuff in the mainline sequel
because it was neat
though maybe we'll get to switch back
and forth between both spider-man in
that one
however as much as i love the gameplay i
felt like the boss fights were a bit
lacking both in number
and execution they didn't want to give
miles too much so he's just dealing with
small fries that peter would wash in
three seconds or hand-me-downs
or holograms of hand-me-downs might as
well make the kid fight tupac
though it's a nice idea to have rhino be
a recurring villain for miles
considering the near
impalement that happened in the original
game we get the usual rhino fair of
tricking him into ramming into something
that'll hurt him if it ain't broke don't
fix it i guess
that's a winning formula going two
decades strong now now we'll mention
that the chase sequences
all two of them are pretty amazing but
the actual brawling with super villains
feels a little undercooked
tinkerer and prowler don't feel that
much different from normal enemy types
they just do more damage and have more
variations of moves i feel like this
series could take a page out of god of
war's book and try to mix the boss
fights
with the elaborate action set pieces a
bit more
there's this disconnect where the
uncharted style destruction porn happens
during these chase sequences or a qte
but the actual fight scene just happens
in a boring walled off arena
i want spidey fighting people on the
side of a collapsing building or
upside down underneath a bridge or on
the back of a moving train
in that regard the main game was
slightly better about boss fights
feeling more intense and explosive
i'm hoping the third game really nails
that aspect with more boss variety more
memorable and unique encounters
and more superhero spectacle mixed in
this is scientifically inaccurate the
city activities are probably the best
they've been in
any spider-man game with a new layer of
depth that they haven't
really had before every little side
quest or good deed has a bit of a story
structure to it which connects all of
them together into an interesting side
narrative that feels like
a really solid back issue of a miles
comic every side objective feels like it
has a tangible effect on the city and
how new yorkers view miles as a hero
hearing the positive and negative press
generated by your spectacular daily
routine from jay jonah jameson
danica hart can give you a good sense
that what you're doing really matters to
the people of new york and that ties
into the main theme of the whole story
the side missions finally matter for
more than just grinding points for
upgrades and costumes
and the upgrades and costumes are great
too miles please son
stop with the identifying markers now
spider-man's got the same shoes as miles
morales
and is wearing his backpack and jacket
from school it's too conspicuous
why do so many of these have hoods that
would never stay up while swinging
everyone has hoods lately hoods are to
this decade as robot arms are to the 90s
hoods hoods hoods ben reilly had a hood
once
you know what happened to him venom
strangled him with it and like his first
day wearing that costume and then he got
rid of it like a smart person
might as well throw a cape on here once
again i'm always for having spider-men
build their own costumes by hand as a
rite of passage
but i wish they acknowledged this to
some extent but anyway i love a lot of
these costumes and i'm happy to see that
all the ones from the comics i was
hoping would make it into the game did
insomniac does a great job of making any
spidey suit look realistic and
functional while also still being
instantly recognizable as a pull from
the source material
just a little bit of seam work and panel
lining on it and any suit can look
badass and photorealism
i just think it's missing that one suit
from life story where otto octavius
brain swapped miles to steal his
exaggerated swagger
an imposter has stolen miles's face
hey wait a minute that wasn't there
before
what the hell now everyone's acting like
that was always there
man this really is based on a comic book
ugh
i'm gonna have to talk about this huh
i know before you ask i know okay i
okay you know what to explain my
feelings about it i'll just show you
what i tweeted when i first saw it quote
the reason i'm so averse to it is
because i got emotionally attached to
this version of peter parker
that includes his voice and his face
changing him so drastically makes me
feel disconnected from him
it's weird and uncanny now it's like if
a close friend came over one day
looking like a completely different
person it would be so jarring and
disturbing hearing a familiar voice
coming out of a stranger's mouth
to a degree i still think this and if i
really had the power to change it back i
would
but more so just to preserve the
continuity because my ocd flares up when
i play these games back to back now and
see something different
but in all fairness that's what happened
when they put webs on the ps1 costume in
the flashback cut scenes in the sequel
that's not how it looked before honestly
it's not that big of a deal
it's still got yuri's awesome voice and
there are more important things in the
world to lose sleep over or start
petitions for
although if i were to put on my tinfoil
hat for a second i don't know if i'd
necessarily buy the official explanation
put forth by the developers
they say they needed someone whose face
shape could match yuri's motion capture
data more closely as they move on to a
new console generation where the
technology has leaked again
understandable but what about these
other characters not everyone looks
exactly like their motion actors but
they kept their faces
andy circus doesn't look like a
chimpanzee but they make that work
and if you wanted it to really match
yuri's topology why not just make a more
youthful version of his own face
we can do that now too it may be just
another case of wanting your brands to
match across various mediums because
yeah if you squint your eyes a little
and look at him from like the right
angle
he looks like tom holland but you could
say that about the old face and andrew
garfield
a really substantial portion of stuff
from the game was made to match or at
least
somewhat evoke the aesthetic and world
building of those movies
because they were more current when the
game first went into development
now it's like six years later and tom is
the new thing so they want some visual
synergy
with that going forward on the flip side
maybe you don't need to change the faces
as much for someone like black cat
because she's in like five cut scenes
but the main character of the whole
franchise whose face you see during all
the most important cutscenes
may need to match the performance
technology better you can't spend
unnecessary time fixing his data to
match the digital head whenever they go
out of sync if there's a simpler option
to just reduce the extra work
if you have an option to cut out
potentially hundreds of additional
unnecessary man-hours of work you're
gonna take it
it's why they recast kratos with someone
substantially taller than his original
voice actor
it'd be a waste of time and money to
keep making this five nine guy try to
fit a nearly seven foot tall character
for every scene in the game
when you could just get a guy who's over
6'3 to do it and shave off the extra
workload
vidja games is a business and they don't
get made if they aren't made efficiently
as cold as that may sound or maybe both
theories are true
or neither of them i don't know i only
have an incredibly basic
understanding of how this technology and
process works
the dots here make the fake dots do the
stuff the same
i'm not a game developer i don't work at
insomniac so i don't know what's going
on behind the scenes
i'm not gonna make up a bunch of fake
[ __ ] and assert it as fact and
everyone trying to do that is being a
dork
it'll take some time to get used to it i
understand that
if there's really no other way then fine
i'll give them a chance
okay can i get back to talking about
miles in this miles game
hey true believers is this the end of
brown spider-man
tune in next week to find out
[Music]
miles himself seems just about perfect i
definitely like him more in this than i
did the previous game
it feels like they tried to give him
unique traits from peter without trying
to feel derivative of spider-verse
so the whole he's also a musician on the
side thing was a neat idea and added
some charm to him
i appreciate that he feels clumsy and
new at the job but isn't just
outright incompetent and can still be
badass when he needs to
i was never frustrated with his lack of
experience because wherever he struggled
felt understandable and justified and it
was nice to see him
learning and polishing his act so to
speak the title character holds it all
together
but i still wish he had a better plot to
journey through
from the big things to the little things
i'd say the game gets a lot right about
its gameplay
but all that has to be tied together
with a story
and on that front i felt like that was
unfortunately the weakest part of the
game for me
the story of miles goes that a year
after gaining his powers milhouse
morlock is now finally ready to take a
more
direct role as the city's secondary
spider-man peter has taught him all the
basics and has to take a trip overseas
for a few weeks for work
leaving the city in miles electrically
crackling hopefully capable hands
but a new gang of young street thugs
with futuristic technology
called the underground start causing
chaos to send a message to the big
corporation that's based itself in new
york
roxanne along the way miles realizes
that his childhood best friend
finn mason is more or less the head of
this street gang and uses her gifted
mind to build their weapons for a
revenge plot against roxanne
after their experimental technology
killed her older brother
miller light begs and pleads for her to
attack roxanne by the book after
discovering how corrupt they are
but she's too consumed with her lust for
vengeance also his uncle is there
and he's a burglar with a cool purple
suit and he didn't really need to be
there but i'm glad he was
miles has to deal with his first
city-wide crisis without peter's help
and figure out how to defeat both his
former friend and the evil corporate
entity that will poison his hometown
i'm noticing a concerning pattern with
insomniac's villains
they seem to be doing that thing from
bendis's ultimate spider-man in the
rainy movies
where every major antagonist has a
personal connection in history with
spidey
before becoming the main bad guy now you
don't have to write them an origin story
and have spidey build a relationship
with them
after they meet for the first time he's
just coincidentally known them for years
obviously the majority of the sinister
six are exceptions to this but with
martin
lee doc ock and now the tinkerer it
looks like all
the main villains will follow this
formula and honestly i feel like that's
going to get old really fast
i get it it's a cheap and easy way to
tug at the old heartstrings when the
main opposing force is an old friend
that lost their way
but it's going to get repetitive if they
do that a third time in a row
i have this sinking feeling that once
again for marvel's spider-man 2
peter's old bestie harry osborne will be
venom and will get the whole
but the main bad guy is my bro i'm so
conflicted scenario which we just saw
twice try something else please
not every villain needs a deep personal
connection to the hero they can just be
a bad guy who mirrors our hero by having
an opposing ideology
and an interesting backstory or
motivation thanos wasn't tony stark's
roommate from college who became jealous
of his success
wilson fisk isn't matt murdock's
childhood best friend that went down a
dark path
keep in mind a bit of this is also
coming from the fact that i'm a huge
eddie brock fan and i don't want them to
forget about him because
i want to see how they'd handle that
character but at this point i'm just
waiting for the moment in a future game
where peter is a boss fight for miles
either because he's wearing the black
suit or because he's got oc brain
oh no my former mentor and best bud oh
no
meanwhile genki becomes the new
hobgoblin and frames ned leeds as
revenge for confusing casual fans
i also just didn't really like the idea
of the antagonists mostly being the same
age as miles
somehow that undermines the feeling of
being an underdog when
the underground are teenagers in over
their heads too
what am i doing with my life i should be
studying
flirting with cheerleaders and playing
wow instead i'm about to get killed in a
robot factory
breaking into a lab full of armed guards
christmas break sure is different this
year
i should be at home taking naps
playing a ton of video games and eating
like a hundred christmas cookies
the corporate stooge behind roxanne
simon krieger
is so generic and lame
and boring and we've seen it a million
times also if he had a mustache he'd
look like lieutenant
dangle the rich guy wants to make money
no matter who gets hurt
people are dead burke even in other
spider-man games we've had this exact
archetype
walker sloan aleister smythe norman
osborne in the last game
but krieger is so devoid of any depth
and so cartoonishly evil and
and strangely he ends up doing very
little in the actual plot of the game
only really serving as a plot device for
finn to turn evil and wants something to
blow up
he has nothing to his character beyond
that function
norman osborn at least wanted to save
his son but krieger just wants to make
fat stacks and act so scummy you almost
want to just let finn rip him a new one
with a glowing nano machine sword
the story's main villain the tinkerer
reminds me of a glaring issue with miles
as a superhero character
he has no interesting villains everyone
he fought in the comics was either
inherited from peter or an alternate
universe take on another character
like scorpion even though the ultimate
universe already had a scorpion
bendis never really got around to giving
miles his own rogues gallery and this
game couldn't give him a compelling
antagonist
without having to make one from scratch
this character is the tinkerer in name
only but
yeah that doesn't mean it's a bad
character oh no they changed that super
memorable and interesting classic
villain
old scientist man who invents things for
crime
peter doesn't have enough those to deal
with this game is however
infinitely funnier if you just replace
her in your mind with the tinkerer from
web of shadows
like can someone mod that for me and
what makes that even more noticeable
is that this has way more in common with
spider-verse than any of miles comics
right down to the fact that it takes
place in winter our family doesn't run
from things miles
our family doesn't give up
pete's a good teacher man they went the
route of making prowler a conflicted
anti-hero that loves miles instead of
the manipulative bastard that died like
13 issues in
even the newer comics decide to do that
too it's funny to me how every
adaptation of miles makes such a huge
deal about differentiating him from
peter
and making him unique because those
initial books have failed so miserably
at doing that
the new run is getting better though
props to everyone working on that one
good work so far
but please give him some original
villains all this game had was
rhino as two boss fights and we fought
him a hundred times before
you know whose life just turned to
absolute garbage in 2011.
hobie brown prowler fans they are just
starving he's never going to be in
anything now
but back to talking about the story i
feel like it has
strong ups and downs for one it started
to become distracting to me how the plot
feels like a rehash of the main game
spider-man has to take down a former
friend and fellow scientist who has used
their intelligence to become a
supervillain to exact revenge on a
corrupt businessman
the war between our vengeance seeking
villain and the corporate bad guy heats
up as their armed forces begin battling
each other in the street
the big macguffin is a fictional sci-fi
object created by the company that makes
people sick
and the villains intend to use it to
punish the corporate stooge for being
callous with other people's lives
which we find out about through a
flashback shown in a video archive after
infiltrating the bad guy's lair
the corporate villains hired mercenary
has a change of heart at the end and
lets spidey pass into the final boss
after being convinced they don't need to
be enemies
the story ends with a big climactic
battle on the company's evil tower
where the hero sacrifices their own
well-being to save the city
and in turn someone close to them makes
a personal sacrifice too that will make
them sad in the sequel
the broad strokes are all the same and
it was a bit disappointing to me because
i just felt like i had played all of
this before but
slightly better two years ago that's not
to say that the story isn't executed
well in miles but it's a story i've
already
seen and it was so much more predictable
because of that
and harder to gravitate to emotionally i
just never really felt attached to
miles's friendship with finn
because it was told to us not shown the
story
insists that they are best friends
through its collectibles and flashbacks
but
by the time this story has begun she's
already had her fall from grace and is
already
squarely the villain at the start of the
story with otto we see him as just a
normal
nice guy for way longer we spend some
time with him and peter together to see
this father and son style bond they have
we see norman osborne slowly breaking
down otto piece by piece as the story
progresses
pushing him further over the edge until
he snaps and lashes out
it just felt more interesting to see his
fall from grace in real time
than have it be told to me through
flashbacks or exposition
i didn't really feel anything for
tinkerer because she had already made
her choice to be the bad guy long before
anything
could be done about it and anytime we
saw her friendship with miles it was
already painted negatively by future
context
rather than allowing the player to just
live in the moment step
off step off i think this flashback
scene to miles and finn's science
project being entered at the fair
would have been so much more effective
if it were placed at the beginning of
the game
then seeing peter and otto there would
have been like foreshadowing to what
would happen next instead of just
creating an obvious parallel
and it would have been kind of
interesting to see miles go through that
location a second time as spider-man so
you're kind of like
as the player reliving his memory of
going through there because you're like
oh i was here like eight hours ago
back before things turned sad dropping
it near the end of the game
felt like backpedaling to try to assure
you that these two were friends when
we've already seen that kinda fall apart
now this scene isn't really heartwarming
it's just kind of hollow
and tedious it's a happy memory for
miles but not for us
because we're only experiencing it after
seeing everything go wrong
and it felt like it hurt the momentum of
the third act to just slow down
this hard in the middle of all that
action i didn't feel much for finn's
revenge or her sacrifice at the end but
something else caught me that saved the
whole thing
the way the people of harlem stood in
solidarity with miles to protect his
identity
it was all characters who we got to know
through the game's side missions people
who i had made my own connections with
as they helped me or
or i helped them in these various
smaller side adventures
it was like the train moment from
spider-man 2 but even more powerful
because i knew who these people were
and i knew why they cared about
spider-man so much on an individual
level the big explosive action story and
tale of revenge and chaos
didn't really do it for me but
everything between was so
perfect that it made up for it
everything about this game that portrays
miles is the hero of his own community
is great
the entire cast of characters from
harlem are all lovable and unique
and seeing miles interact with them and
be accepted by them is really touching
peter is a hero for new yorkers sure but
he keeps them at arm's length to protect
them so very few of them know anything
about him
with miles he still values his secret
identity but a few of his neighbors know
it's him under the mask
and protect that information with their
lives because they care so much about
him
he's one of them and he has this
symbiotic relationship with harlem
where the people in it push him to be
better and he does the same for them
peter and miles both spend a lot of time
in these games down on the street
helping people in a very personal way
they're not above
finding lost pets fixing broken plumbing
and feeding the homeless
that's what makes them both so human
compared to other heroes
remembering that no good deed is too
small
peter keeps mostly to himself content
with a generally thankless job
but miles allows himself to love and be
loved by these people he helps
miles has a talent for connecting with
people that peter never really had
they both do the right thing but they do
it a little differently
that's what makes spider-man so special
but also what makes
miles special as spider-man keep going
kid
[Music]
[Music]
you